[Music]
Kenny I remove implicit bias from the
hiring process
it's remove entirely remove now right
but I I understand I've had multiple
people tell me that it's already
reducing the impact of implicit bias so
they're already happy with the with what
they're seeing so what is implicit bias
first of all it's important to
understand that implicit bias and
explicit bias are two different things
implicit bias is stuff that you're not
conscious of you're not aware of it it's
hard for you to control it's probably
impossible for you to control it's
impossible for you to control right now
on demand you might be able to alter it
by exposing yourself to different
situations or whatever and changing what
we and machine learning call priors
right so changing your experiences so
maybe if you see more women in senior
positions you'll become less implicitly
sexist or something like that but anyway
explicit bias is like I'm gonna choose
to only work with women or I'm gonna
choose only to work with men and I know
that an unconscious about it so HR
departments are reasonably good at
getting people who hopefully they
honestly are saying yeah I want to I
want I'm not going to be racist or
sexist or whatever it's you know I'm not
going to worry about how long somebody's
name is or what the country of origin of
someone of their ancestors is right but
so hopefully HR people can spot the the
people who sincerely are neutral but at
least at the explicit level but at the
implicit level there there's a lot of
evidence that that something else might
be going at again we don't know for sure
if it's implicit or explicit but what we
do know is that in the paper we did in
2017 on one of my co-authors Eileen
Callahan had this brilliant idea of
looking at the resume data that so
there's a famous study that showed that
you have identical resumes and the only
thing you do is have more African
American names versus European American
names and the people with European
American names get 50% more
to interview and what nothing else
changed and so now people are talking
about widening their CVS so they just so
they get that chance to interview so
anyway the this it looks by the measures
that we used with with the vector spaces
as if the the data in the implicit bias
that also explains implicit bias also
explains that those traces on the resume
so does that mean people were looking at
it and explicitly saying oh I think
that's an african-american or were they
just going through huge stacks of of CDs
and and some didn't jump out at them in
the same way that others did because
they're pretty sure when it comes down
to like they're all sitting in the room
together that that that point was okay
and so what the AI is doing for them is
it's it's helping them pick out the
characteristics they're looking for and
ignoring the other characteristics so
lets helping its they're helping them to
tack the things that they wanted to be
when they were sitting in the room with
multiple eyes looking at something that
they were looking at the right starting
spaced place and then they're able to
find they're finding people that were
falling through the cracks a lot of
people have troubled there's not enough
good people applying or that they
thought that weren't enough good people
applying but actually they were missing
people because they didn't see the
qualifications bearing in the other
stuff when they're leafing through these
stacks so a lot of people are reporting
that they have great data or they're
getting they're very pleased with the
results
but that's privately and it's off the
record and I can't get anyone to go on
the record so I just recently at
Princeton the Center for information
technology policy ran a meeting about AI
in somebody again in Chatham House I
can't say who it was but an organization
that sort of it's sort of between
corporate and and and well only it's a
special kind of organization they said
that they're going to try to do this and
so I begged them to document it I said
look you're in a different situation you
don't have ordinary customers please
please document the results fully and
then publish papers about it so we can
really see what the outcomes are so I
hope we'll have that data but so far I
can only tell you that people
saying it really is working what are the
possible shortfalls of that kind of
situation well first of all being sure
that you can you can eliminate bias that
way no there's all kinds of ways you can
accidentally pick up on things so like
even if you don't have gender you might
recognize gender from the name for
example so there's there's ways that
machine learning picks up on
regularities that are illegal and you
have again you have to do your own
auditing and make sure that that isn't
happening of course any time you put you
scan something and make it digital then
that makes it available to hacking so
you have to be careful about that and I
guess the biggest thing is don't believe
that just because you've automated part
of a process you've made it fair you
know you have to keep checking just like
anything else you keep you keep going to
improve but yeah when you when you put
these things in front of you
and it when you write them down then
yeah you have the you have the potential
to keep improving
I guess there's one other thing which I
haven't mentioned which is that once
you've automated the process you do open
the door for somebody who is say an evil
racist to go in and actually tweak
things and make it so that you know you
get all one race right so so you need to
make sure that there's adequate
oversight and auditing regular auditing
because the one of the people worried
about accidentally introducing bias and
that's you know good we should worry
about that but we should be really
worried about deliberately introducing
bias that that's the thing that I think
again because people think artificial
intelligence is like you know space
aliens that are kind of or they actually
it's almost like that sort of the
greco-roman or or Nordic gods or
something like you know maybe we can
pray to them correctly and they'll give
us what we want you know but that but
they're capricious and we're not sure
you know no it's not like that
it's it's it really is something that we
we have an opportunity to try to fix it
and it works in systematic ways but it's
important to understand that people are
writing it and that means that some some
people will make mistakes some people
will be sloppy something
we'll do what they seriously think is
the best thing but it actually isn't
legal and some people will go out of
their way to do bad things because
they're just vandals or because that's
how they got elected or you know
whatever
[Music]